Joy Reid very upset is that irony by the
Supreme Court's decision to get rid of
affirmative action in college admissions
and Jerry Reed's upset because she says
with that affirmative action she never
would have gotten into Harvard I got
into Harvard only because of affirmative
action I am shocked shocked I went to a
school no one had ever heard of in
Denver Colorado in a small suburb I
didn't go to Exeter or Andover I didn't
have college test prep I just happened
to be really nerdy and smart and have
really good grades the good SAT scores
but someone came to Denver Colorado to
look for me a Harvard recruiter flew to
Denver and I met up with her at the
Village Inn Restaurant and did a
pre-interview to get to to pull me into
Harvard she says I didn't get into
Harvard because I was given an unfair
Advantage because I was unqualified but
then I was given an artificial boost and
then I was allowed in that's not no
that's not affirmative action yes it is
that is what affirmative action is